hi i'm spencer j gilbert welcome to the
jackass honest trailer commentary
that would've been awesome um this is
i'm here with danielle uh
uh it's a it's a beautiful day in the
neighborhood here because we get to talk
about the jackass franchise um
one that is near and dear to our hearts
but as i'm uh scamming through the
comments uh a lot of you hate and are
disgusted by so maybe we'll try to
explain
all right
this uh maybe the maybe it's cross uh
it's international appeal is low i don't
know we'll get to the bottom of it
though hey danielle uh how do you feel
about the jackass movies
um
you know there's a lot of them and we i
think we've got a lot of the stuff that
i really love and we'll talk about it in
the trailer there's a lot of parts that
i love of each movie and then i have to
watch a lot of them like this
and it's uh it's one of those things
where
maybe when i was younger
maybe because we didn't have phones
where you could just like take pictures
of everything and video and it looked
amazing
but i
i i've discovered that there are i have
obviously a bunch of different groups of
friends and apparently just a bunch of
my butcher dude friends
they just do this thing where they like
send each other pictures of their poop
and i'm like i don't
[Laughter]
you know uh it's very much that mortal
kombat thing like where raiden is like
you're going to out world where i cannot
follow like good for you congratulations
like i won't be there
um so yeah and you'll see it as we even
replay this very censored trailer there
will be moments where i just have to
like cover my face because i don't do
well with fluids
fluids okay got it got it only fluids
and there's plenty of those yeah and
please uh click over after this to our
to our by the numbers episode where we
analyze just how many fluids and where
they go um which is uh which is it
should be on this channel maybe in the
related videos over here
the answer will not surprise you will
not surprise you exactly
um look i love these films i'm not gonna
make any secret of it it was so fun to
revisit them i love the tv show
i
am a product of uh
i guess mid-90s skateboarding culture
where i would just get those i would get
like thrasher video magazines 411 video
magazines thrasher tape like you would
watch tapes of people hurting themselves
on skateboards um and there would be
little skits in between usually if them
hurting themselves in a different funny
way and i don't know i mean grit it got
me when i was you know eight nine 10 11
like somewhere in that range and that
just became a very foundational part of
my sense of humor and uh it's it feels
like uh like an old favorite hoodie you
know going back to see the jackass uh
guys and i think that there is something
very
sweet about them um because they are
like you know with some exceptions uh
very sweet guys who all seem to
genuinely like hanging out with each
other and it's it's real it's not like a
reality tv way like you can't fake that
kind of camaraderie over that many
decades
it's just it's just nice to see them all
hang out with each other like
enduring male friendship what a
beautiful thing to see on camera you
don't you don't get that very often so i
i think that there's
it still makes me laugh yes it's
juvenile um
uh yes i'm i'm biased because uh that
was like the thing that made me laugh
in the olden days but
god it just it it gets me every single
time and and the gross out stuff like
i don't know yes it's gross i am very
grossed out by what they're doing a lot
of the time i do think it is disgusting
and i would never do that
but it's not me
they're doing it and they're having a
good time so i
i don't know uh it's a beautiful
testament to human frailty and the the
um it's it's kind of spitting in the
face of the uh the untouchable macho
stereotype of like a guy who like never
winces and like endures pain stoically
and doesn't it doesn't like well stands
alone and stuff like that and this is
like walks away from explosions and like
that
yeah i got kicked in the nuts it hurts
give me a high five like that seems to
be
i'll hug it it is like because it does
feel like it's just a different kind of
like hey we've been through the [ __ ]
together just in this case it's actual
um but it does feel like one of those
things and it does uh uh i think a thing
i said that didn't make it into the
trailer was that like it does it feels
very much like hey
if you're if you're just not going to
college this is like the frat experience
of you know we're all like doing these
things and it bonds us because we're all
doing them together and no one is and in
this case i'm like with a lot of frats
where it's like you know people yelling
at you and calling you names and stuff
this is very much like i believe in you
i believe you can drink that
like i believe that you can
you know
i trust in your ability to put that car
like i believe in you you know
and so i i do enjoy very much that like
hey we're all in this together
we're all in this together yeah um and
so are you viewer so let's all watch the
honest trailer for jackass together and
experience uh danielle's reactions in
real time
[Music]
in the 1800s the motion picture was born
with the advent of synchronized sound
film entered a golden age
[Music]
now just as nicole kidman welcomes us
back to theaters we can count ourselves
among the lucky people who are blessed
we haven't had a chance to talk about
the nicole kidman amc maybe we did on an
sju or something like that
but that's really endured um in my mind
this is like a iconic moment in film
history don't you think it's just such a
it can never be repeated
um
it is so incredibly specific to this
like if they ever do a
i love pandemic or like whatever on ph
one like this is definitely
like an i heart pandemic moment of like
oh remember that time when nicole kidman
was like theater it takes you back to
and she's just sitting there watching it
and whatever terrible wig they have her
in that day and
uh various movies are playing and she's
alone in a theater because she's nicole
goodman why would there be other people
around yeah and uh and people memeing it
and i don't know if this is true but
someone tweeted that they were in a
theater and someone handed out like all
the words on a piece of paper and
honestly i've been to theaters
especially as we got back all weirdos
these days so like i don't doubt that
someone did the calcification of that
where they like handed out like music
and lyrics for you to like say along
with it people were making fun of it but
you know what if someone handed me the
full transcribe or people just started
talking with her
somehow heartbreak feels good here yeah
i'm gonna do that heartbreak feels good
here yeah i'm gonna say it it's the
biggest cheer to every movie i've been
in the last two months including movies
that people love like everything
everywhere all at once
people love that movie they were crying
as they walked out there was not a
bigger cheer than when nicole kidman
came on screen every single time the
last like five movies i've seen to quote
nicole kidman it's an indescribable
feeling um there's
there's just something beyond
description when you when you see it it
just hits so good uh kind of like a
jackass uh nut shot so on with the
trailer
to be alive during the true peak of
cinema
[Applause]
the jackass movies
when some skaters realize that not
everybody cares about kickflips but
everyone loves a nutshot jackass was
born growing from its humble roots in
the cky and big brother videos to
becoming the top-rated show on mtv
[Music]
i will encourage everyone to go find um
the early seek like the first cky video
on
dailymotion
probably the only place left
maybe yeah vimeo gonna get a
vhs on ebay or something like that um it
is like
distilled jackass chaos it's like the
crack cocaine of jackass it's really
just like
quick cuts of like them screaming at
somebody in public or getting hit in the
nuts or falling off their skateboard if
you like jackass like down to its raw's
form and it's like it's um
bam ryan dunn
uh rob himself who's only in the first
movie uh and then like some of the other
like periphery characters you'll see uh
around because jackass is actually the
fusion of two different camps there's
the cky guys who are just like they're
in the suburbs in um
pennsylvania i think i think so yeah
yeah and they're like making weird
little videos like that and then johnny
knoxville
stevo and um pontius are over um i guess
in la uh
working on um trying to get into the big
brother
skate
scene uh um which was a great magazine
uh if you if you look up old issues with
big brother is fantastic and worth your
time um but those it's like the avengers
coming together really cky and big
brother uh jeff germain ran the magazine
actually so that's that's where he came
in um
and that's how jackass was born a little
history lesson for all of you
uh okay keep going
back when that actually meant something
jackass would find its highest
expression on the big screen with a
debut that used a bigger budget to
really elevate the material
a sequel that proved the series as no
ball
the third one that's yeah i'll say it a
better use of 3d than avatar
pause
and i stand by that i mean
i well i'm going to moderate that
slightly um i think it's as good a use
of 3d as avatar
and one of the only movies that
justifies being in 3d what say you
daniel i will say it's one of the
because it very much like we um we went
through that period where obviously
there was avatar and it was so big
because avatar was specifically shot to
be in 3d and so the experience isn't
just the same as like oh well that leg
looks like it's closer to me than it
would be it's like you don't know i'm
going to convert it to 3d in post yeah
yeah i'm like in this magical um
land of
of the navi and like hair tails the bang
or like whatever
and
jackass i believe was filmed
specifically 3d to be in 3d so it also
gives you that same immersive experience
rather than like you said just like
throwing 3d in post it's like oh well
smog is closer that's tight
oh here comes smog
yeah that was a that was a dark time it
literally dark time because part of the
you could never get it like bright
enough or something when you when you
did it there were so many like muddy 3d
interpretations like uh in that era and
it was just never worth me going glasses
over glasses for i mean now these days
you can get clip-on 3ds for for your uh
glasses but back then it was just
glasses over glasses i already got a big
head so the glasses that they give you
are already like not great enough so i
have to put them over
yeah so i mean you can see an avatar was
fine for me but like you said with the
post stuff it's like well i can't see
anything i think the last one of those
that i went to was probably force
awakens and i was like okay
yeah yeah and it's even worse to be in a
bad seat in a 3d movie theater than a
than a real one
but mark my words i will be there uh for
avatar 2 dead center uh in
5d i will be wearing man
i i look i want to i want a theater
usher well someone paid like a tony and
tina's wedding just come up and slap me
on the face with like their hair tail
yeah i want ponytail slaps um i think
that every time they go underwater they
should submerge at least your legs in
the in the theater
right or just like have to see i was
gonna say something i've been watching
too much jackass i was gonna say or just
like have someone spit in your mouth and
it's like i just wanted to
i've been watching too much jackass
it's become a problem it has shaped the
way that my world works for the next
like two weeks and i apologize to
everyone oh i love it um let's actually
sprinkle in some fan questions
throughout instead of instead of uh
hoarding them all smog-like until the
end um benjamin bramwich asks where's
bad grandpa
we we restricted it that's a jackass
presents bad gramps this is just the
main line uh jackass film bagram is also
pretty good i wouldn't put it up there i
put it below all of
the four canon films
um but above the uh jackass presents
like matt hoffman's evil bmx circus or
whatever that was um
i don't know
if if we were gonna and i don't think
this was a jackass presents i think this
was just like a knoxville and pontius
production but i would also put in like
action point or whatever it was i don't
know we were going to include that
because all of those stunts were real
and johnny knoxville for real knocked
out and i so yeah
um evan j pritzker says there's a
theater near me that plays at least one
honest trailer before movies that's
awesome wow cool
did we get paid for that i was going to
say yeah yeah that's not the i haven't
no we're not going to be like them we're
not going to
actually don't tell us we don't even
need to know uh just enjoy um and yeah
let let's not uh be like the peop the
goblins who who uh pull our trailers for
having like you know a picture of
something that's not uh licensed or
whatever um
let's just keep watching the trailer
we'll we'll get to more questions later
ah screw it a legacy sequel that's more
nostalgic than all the nerd franchises
combined
you clapped when andrew garfield stepped
out in the spider suit i clapped when
dave england stepped out of his pooping
cardigan
i did
ah
cinema
meet the jackasses
a bunch of clowns and the world is their
circus there's ringleader johnny
knoxville a failed actor that's a
classic who turned into a stunt man who
turned back into a failed actor who
turned back into a stunt man
uh pause
someone pointed out that he also turned
back no failed actor with action point
but i think i should point
he that's a that's like a stuntman
acting combo performance yeah it's
definitely one of those ones where it's
like i want to take the things that i
know people love about what we do and
then put a narrative around it because
it's got everything it's got like all of
the stunts and they're all real and it's
all done by them real time and then it's
got like a story that goes around it
which is based on something that was
true it's based on um
action point or action park whatever
like this incredibly deadly slap shot
put together amusement park and it's
also got like the i'm a grandpa but i'm
naughty it's like all of the things that
they really like combined into one thing
that didn't work for anyone
yeah
um
now people chime in outlaw tadpole
writes i found honest trailers from a
theater playing the fast five honest
trailer um i guess this is a thing and
you know what this this tracks because
i do not consider myself uh famous in
any definition of the word except when
i'm getting my ticket taken at a movie
theater usually that's the only time
he's either i'm like
outside a panel at comic-con or having
my ticket ripped at a movie theater
someone's like honest trailers i go yeah
on australia
that's the only time i get like the
fight club moment so i guess our fan
base is entirely ushers and and uh
concession stand workers uh go to uh go
to an amusement park in the summer too
you'll get it that's the only time i get
it
um there's amusement parks in the summer
um yeah that's oh you're right when i
went to disneyland the galaxy's edge uh
photo guy was like on his trailers yeah
it's the only and it only happens once
it's like once i and it's exactly those
ones um but yeah that's the only time it
happens also
uh
yeah no like that so i'm trying to think
if there's anything else but that's when
we get recognized hopefully uh that
trend continues i will
uh
best fan base one could ever hope to uh
to have around them because like that's
the best people come on yeah and one of
them did it in front of one of my
sisters and i was like see i do have a
real job
[Laughter]
at universal studios
um ryan writes imagine them playing a
25-minute cinemasins video before
they should do that before that movie
they should do it after don't breathe
because of the length that's not a
comment on the quality yeah like that
but just just the length of the video
would make me laugh i think after the
credits roll they should or during the
credits they should they should start
dinging starts how it should have ended
after the ending
or they can just show some of my um gas
station tv videos which is the other
time i feel famous is when what about oh
i didn't like it on that i do
yeah apparently uh some old video and my
uh my aunt was like hey i saw you on gas
station tv and i was like great i do
have a job
we used to be on planes somewhere i used
to have to upload stuff for planes
back in the old way
like
i shouldn't actually call out but we
were on some planes at some point along
with smosh and clever back in those days
wow how bored do you have to be on an
airplane
what's the movie
um watching clever tv coverage of like
something or like watching a smosh video
like everyone's got to sleep uh all
right let's watch uh on australis
bamargera who has the perfect mixture of
genius stupidity and sadism to take
ideas from good to great we have a
weight going up and it's supposed to hit
me in the nuts but
i prefer to have like
instead of the weight and then instead
of the nuts it'll be my
brian dodd yeah
i know that he's a uh a
troubled man who's in some trouble right
now but i do think that the fourth movie
suffered from the lack of bam and his
parents uh don't you think
he's a pillar of the jackass franchise
and obviously like uh wish him well hope
he's doing great i know all those dudes
were super bummed that he couldn't be in
the fourth movie um and talked about it
a bunch
but yeah i mean he he is such a i mean
he was so popular they gave him his own
show they were like nah you can't just
torture your parents for like three
minutes at a time we need to see an
entire 22 minutes of you making your
family just feel like crap
yeah granted that one was definitely i
don't want to say they were staged or
they were in on it but when it's in your
own home and like
you're not like why is there a camera
crew filming me getting breakfast yeah
something's probably going to happen
yeah these were the same where he would
just like sneak up on them while they
were sleeping this is very much like bam
but that you've got miked
yeah you might you're wearing a love
so
but um
yeah there's there's uh we don't have
any delete seeds today sorry because
they're all everything we cut was
because it was too disgusting but there
was a um
there's moments in the uh in the jackass
movies where
bam instead of writing anything it might
seem like charlie from always sunny
instead of writing anything he just
draws a diagram of what he thinks is
going to be funny and then faxed it to
los angeles so you can just sit there
and just draw like big guy tied with
rope to little guy falls off cliff and
then big guy makes bungee jump like and
then just fax that picture it was it's
genius in a really dumb way it's so
funny and because it is they are perfect
they're perfect diagrams that's exactly
what they wind up doing um almost like a
blueprint but it is one of those things
where it's also like yo if someone comes
to like clean his apartment and just
finds all of these videos of various men
being tor
pictures of like here's how i torture
men like you definitely
you're putting you're putting a red flag
on that yeah
um all right let's keep going
ryan don whose death left a void not
even four zoomers and a guy named
poopies could fill that's it's a card
story he already knows that
that's your
that's my favorite one
for a second we have a question um from
jeffrey elberton what are your favorite
jackass duns and pranks and some other
people ask this as well uh what are the
ones you can't watch your least
favorites
okay so literally we just passed my
favorite prank little car
is my favorite thing that they have ever
done
and 90 i mean only 10 of it is the
actual insertion of the car
90 of it is the doctor
he is
so funny and just like not even
judgmental he's just like oh there's
like a that looks like a little car and
at the end he's even like look like
don't tell your girlfriend or if you
have a boyfriend don't tell your
boyfriend that guy knows and that's one
too many and it was so like it wasn't it
was just it was literally like one of
those sun i'm gonna uh you know always
wear sunscreen and don't tell people
about the little car up your butt and it
makes me laugh every single time i watch
it um ones i cannot watch uh
most of them are in here so you'll see
it when i cover my face
yeah i picked my least favorite uh that
comes up later in this trailer which is
the paper cut uh test something about
what that's right
oh i just could not watch them do that i
couldn't i listened to it and that was
hard enough um that really got me in a
way that like
literally more painful things didn't
upset me but that for some reason was um
was really just the worst well because
you could get those you're not gonna get
hit by a bull but you're definitely
going to get a paper cut
yeah ooh i know what that feels like
yeah
the bulls one yeah what are you saying
right
i'll just say i think there was so adam
also in the chat said that was his least
favorite but yeah that one is that one's
the hardest one as they also avid fan
that's the one i do turn away from yeah
i do think that the uh the poo cocktail
supreme in jackass 3d
that got the biggest pop out of me in
the theater uh when i saw it with the 3d
glasses because that just lent itself so
well uh to three dimensions
um
i have to think about giant hand
slapping one oh god
it's so fun it works out so perfectly
and i will i will say this um i didn't
go on about it in my writing for the
trailer because i knew i was going to
talk about it here
you don't have to like wrestling but i
will tell you right now
they do a whole basically a mini like a
like a a a uh
an all-star a medley a hey like greatest
hits of a bunch of jackass stunts during
wrestlemania and it's really really
funny and i'm sure you can find it on
like youtube or whatever if you don't
want to give [ __ ] your money um like
they like wwe does um after a while
start like loading these clips onto
youtube so you can probably find it on
their official channel it's so funny
it's everything you like except without
the fluids so it's everything i like
there you go johnny without people
getting knocked out uh and then waking
up and asking if butterbean is okay it's
better being okay like that also has to
be mentioned i'm just like that is an
all-time pull from somebody who is
definitely concussed
to still pull that off this is great
uh all right let's keep watching
steve oh whose early stunts feel like
watching an addict hit their low point
but whose later stunts are even harder
to watch because my god how could you do
that sober
chris pontius a wild boy who's keeping
sketchy animal handlers in business
there's no doubt in my mind when you hit
a ball full of bees you're going to get
stuff well i made the mistake of showing
them what sea cucumbers do when they're
threatened venomous shout out to wild
boys great show
and keeping the animal kingdom welfare
[Music]
yeah pause i think one of the most
fascinating things from uh by the
numbers uh is that pontius is the only
one
of the entire crew that doesn't get a
head injury never gets hit in the head
oh
the entire uh across all four films he
is never once um suffers a traumatic
head injury which they all do in one
form or another all of them get hit in
the head they have the team for him but
he
is more of a uh dick and balls kind of
guy he knows his lane he really is he's
like the best role player on a
championship team of like he plays
defense he boxes out he's always there
to make the right play
the right play is usually having some
small animal uh sting or bite his
johnson
or just being buck-ass naked somewhere
yeah he's really good at just being
buck-ass naked yes he is yeah god bless
every team needs one he's got that liz
of confidence i can't i can't you know
okay keep going
preston lacey and jason weyman akuna
who've dedicated their lives to
exploring mass and gravity
dave england who has the closest thing
to a character arc by going from guy who
freaked out during beehive tetherball
to guy who stood pretty still during
beehive penis ball
[Laughter]
and danger aaron who proves that if
you're not as cute or famous as the
others you're probably gonna get stuck
doing the worst
talk to it aaron try to calm it down oh
no it's going for the salmon
off of this
bed he is the
low-key mvp of um of i think the crew
and
they don't like him clearly
apparently he used to be a drunk a-hole
and but like i i guess he used to really
be
maybe their sober policy for this fourth
one was a big part of
dave i guess he used to get a little too
crispy in between his name he calls
himself danger aaron and he uh
and he had like this whole character and
his motto like was safety first and
stuff like that and i think that they
just
found that annoying and then would
make him do
truly truly he has to do all of the
worse stuff certainly in the last movie
but also in jack has two and a little
bit and three uh
so
yeah wow you think he gets paid more
probably not right he probably gets paid
less because
honestly truly yeah
wow i mean
he makes he's the only one who i think
has like
real psychological damage from these
movies i think they all have injuries
like they all their bodies are all
creaky at this point but he in that bear
prank and in that bed of nails uh snake
prank like he is making faces and noises
that i imagine
don't show up outside of like a cia
black site
yeah like i am like uh i bet like when
it's someone's party and they're all in
the same room they're all like very
intense and like waiting for something
to happen but i think with him he walks
by any zoo and he's like well i'm
screwed
yes yeah he can't go to the zoo anymore
um it's over yeah yeah no
uh well props to him because he he
really put it all on the line for i
think that bear
as sadistic as it was it was probably
that and the silence of the lamb sketch
were my two favorites from uh from
jackass he's the mvp of the fourth movie
he carries the fourth movie he really
does it's that close yeah
so uh round of applause for danger aaron
that's right
carrying the whole movie on a sack
thank you
anytime
all right keep going
geez louise i hope he gets paid more for
these things or at least some dental
insurance
want to see something that will scar you
for life great because every jackass
movie has at least one of those moments
but the thing that makes jackass better
than the obviously fake prank shows the
amateur stunt youtubers and all the
other people that they've influenced is
the simple joy of watching a bunch of
lifelong friends hang out and goof off
together oh isn't it so awesome that
they all cheer and hug after every stunt
makes me wish i was part of their family
uh maybe an uncle or something
okay how about a job be on the camera
nope never mind pause no place is safe
i
something we kind of forgot to
work in here is like there's so many
random cameos in this movies in these
movies like
rip taylor that's i mean that's fun he
ends everyone um john waters is in there
luke wilson i think is in like um
he's in there in the when they're in
india and it's like were they shooting
darjeeling unlimited or was this the
inspo for it
you know it's hard to say once you start
getting that i can take a vacation with
my buddy's money everything becomes you
know that that's what happened to adam
sandler he just started making movies
we're getting vacations with his friends
um
yeah scott is it there
there's and especially if you watch like
the bonus stuff like in 2.5 and a bunch
of other things obviously they uh expand
on stunts and what they were like but
they also showed you stuff that they
didn't really get to show you and so you
really get um a good feel of what it
looks like to watch uh oscar winners 36
mafia get sprayed with a nerf gun full
of pee
worth your time worth its weight in gold
some might say well it's actually i mean
it is it's not that long so if you're
really into the franchise and you
haven't seen those bonuses go check them
out yeah the poses are great i'm very
excited for 4.5 um i'm sure there's
going to be lots of good stuff in there
uh okay let's keep going
so pop your shirt off and enjoy the last
remaining slapstick comedy franchise
that shows young men what healthy
masculinity looks like i can't take them
off unless you give me permission
i do think she was a fantastic addition
i wish there was more of her rachel
something yeah rachel wolfson la la
comic i believe before yeah
uh she was great and i do look i like
all of the
new editions um poopy's feels like he's
always been a part of the part of that
group
i mean a surfer an ex-surfer named
poopy's
you would that'd be tough to say is not
part of jackass
but i think that uh
you're missing the like the history
obviously and it's just the fact that
they were there when ryan dunn and bam
weren't
i think like
they just it felt like okay well
we need to fill these slots um whereas i
think part of the appeal is like it's so
it's so seemingly natural that these
guys all hung out with each other from
the time they were teenagers to today
but i still i think that they like they
should have had like a like a peacock
series which is like son of jackass
where they all got to stun so then they
the new class yeah the new class they
get promoted into the movies i should
wish that they should be doing that
right now yeah i like i i liked all the
new additions but it definitely felt
very much like we've gotta fill a hole i
do think that rachel was amazing and
charming and and did a great job i
thought they all did a great job um
because i can't look
i don't care what you say if someone's
getting that stuff done to them they
they are working um
at a one percent of humanity level that
like most of us could not do if you can
continuously lick a taser uh you you've
earned it you earned it you're under it
buy that house
yeah get that motorcycle
and like jane campion says you're doing
it against the boys
[Laughter]
so round of applause
uh okay let's keep going
comfortable in our own skin in that it's
still on our bodies
[Applause]
because while these guys are no longer
that young they'll always be dumb what's
antidote mean i don't even know was the
dick hair necessary absolutely
i don't know i'm stupid and still full
of well you know i was rubbing horse on
my face for weeks test that out
why are you looking at me like that
[Laughter]
i can't even get a [ __ ] heart
it was water
that wasn't water
i'm a vegetarian
you don't get that much
yeah paz where do you get five gallons
of pig semen
i mean i guess you gotta know a guy we
just don't know guy
you just got to know a guy i had to get
a barrel of lube one time for a smosh
video for smosh games a barrel yeah uh
i don't know if it applies to this but
if you ever a need for large quantities
of stuff you don't know how to get find
a factory and usually they have expired
uh like technically expired inventory
like the date means they can't sell
anymore even if it's not bad and that's
how we were able to get a bunch of lube
for a smosh games video so maybe if
there's some type of farm
with some type of you know sell by date
you'd be able to
get it from there please please don't
please don't buy expired pick siemen
i feel like we have to say that
perfectly
pixie it's expired
not
good
at that point just mix glue and water
that's just government overreach telling
you when you can and can't use your own
pig savings well they don't pasteurize
the pig semen so
yours maybe i i can it you know i'm a
prepper you never know when [ __ ] hits
the fan when you're gonna need to pop
open a fresh can
look i get mine from whole foods so yeah
yeah i pay i go to arowand and get a
charcoal activated uh pig's funk
um
sorry
that's a record
let's keep watching
starring the best recurring bits in
these movies
permanent bodily harm
he's a total smiley face dude
oh the balls
[Music]
fun with dioramas
[Applause]
there you go
one thing i loved about that um
uh what's his name he's that ufc
heavyweight champion in the world uh
punching the guy in the cup is that they
were doing this uh aside from the clip
you just saw they were all masked and
socially distanced and they were doing
it
like hey safety first you got everybody
everybody be careful be careful be safe
be secure all right punch this guy in
the nuts as hard as you absolutely can
yeah uh concussions contusions fine
kavid no thank you no no no no but i
thought that was that was cute that made
it uh extra funny to me um okay let's
let's keep watching
bam's weird mumble voice intros and this
is the brand
and it's gonna suck i just lost this
load of fans but i gained four in key
west and they're heavy
looks like dunn's up next fat fat is
hungry for some chocolate so now i'm
gonna feed them and the funniest joke of
all the disclaimer the stunts in this
movie were performed by professionals
they're professional in that they are
paid for it that's that makes you a pro
and they're freelancers
they're surrounded by professionals you
know there's medics uh there's
definitely safety people on set and
ready to uh you know save a life
but we've seen where they come from
they're well is there like i imagine
there is like an actual stuntman school
or like training for yeah yeah yeah you
take like fight combat and all that
stuff i had to take some of it uh in
college um but yeah there's just like a
whole thing where they teach you all
about stuff like how to take a fall like
all kinds of uh stuntman training well
they learn the natural way you know they
learn by doing
you can only read about it so many times
in post
i here for book learning yeah
the jackass stunt school would or like
summer camp oh i take me back take me
there um
we should be franchising that right now
uh and get a really good lawyer okay uh
like the best of lawyers it's like the
start like the 5 000 star wars
experience hotel but instead it's
jackass like you you might not yeah
an usher's gonna tease you
you would have to have different levels
there's gotta be like a jackass you know
it'll be you know different consent
levels sure well and then it also saves
us because like if you're getting the
full
experience we're gonna need them
cleaning fees my homie yeah yeah yeah
all the um all the furniture and and
sheets should be disposable in your room
everything covered in classic like your
grandma's yeah
uh uh okay let's let's wrap this up
pain strains and oh god my balls
[Music]
simpsons did it
simpsons did it
simpsons did it
[Music]
um yeah sorry for the dated reference
but that's when i think whenever
somebody gets hit by a football right
yeah
and then also uh you could do that um
these days with uh sadly uh tick tock
did it because there's a lot of there's
a lot of tick tock pranks that like
people pointed out uh have been done
before that were in jackass forever and
look you know there's writer's rooms for
these things maybe there's some
influence but uh
you know it's different to see uh stevo
do the do the like stay silent while you
get hurt thing then uh you know
uh barf mcgee the tick the the prank
tick talker and look either uh you enjoy
one more because you know that at the
end of the day they do have medics and
people around to make sure they don't
get hurt or you enjoy the other because
you know they don't have that or
insurance so it's just mom
whatever whatever is your your body
floaty you just like
we have no judgments
uh okay let's let's let's hit some fan
questions here because we don't have any
uh deleted scenes because they're
they're too hot for youtube um
everything we cut is just uh blood or
poop genuinely like this has to already
this is like the most censored honest
trailer we've ever done probably there's
like go girls
show girls is definitely up there and um
saw i remember we just had this like
three minute long gore montage that's
just a blurry screen the whole time
which is probably the most unbroken
piece of censorship um
but yeah uh showgirls for sure adam
alberta is there any celebrity you
despise that you'd want to see go
through these stunts my choice is jared
leto i mean that'd be fun to watch jared
leto do this but i don't think it's like
i would want them to enjoy it
part of the fun is like
like i like seeing machine gun kelly get
hit with a giant
slap hand um
but uh he was a willing participant in
that i think that's part of it it's it's
not unsuspecting people they've like
signed up to do yeah yeah
yeah because that's also yeah i agree
like it's as much fun as it would be to
see some of those things happen like i
do want it to be someone who's like yeah
like i'm in on the joke like we're all a
team and like afterwards we're gonna go
get drinks you know like not the same as
you know a punk where it's like oh no
beyonce thinks that she ruined christmas
it's very much i want to see snooki you
know back handspring and
nope not gonna make no sense
eric andre was like genuinely stoked
when he got yeah he was like yes like he
was like so excited that he finally got
to be
uh
luke duncan's ass uh if you guys could
bring your own idea for a jackass stunt
celebrity prank what would it be mine
would be something where nicole kidman
has to watch jackass
like a clockwork orange style with like
her eyes just like opened artificially
and like strapped to the chair
yeah i think the croc the clockwork
orange uh nicole kidman
um jackass prank show would be would be
pretty good that would be pretty good
that would be really funny oh gosh who
would i want to see do
i don't know why i have no justification
for this i just think it would be really
funny i think that olivia coleman
just doing a bunch of i don't know why i
think that would be funny but i think
that that's like secretly hilarious you
know well she's got she's not like she's
had a serious uh british comedy
background yes
so yeah yeah i think that she would
enjoy it i think we'd get like some
tutting because she would think that
that was funny um
you know like a uh uh
maybe do a stunt where it's like you
know they've got her all fancy dressed
up and she's drinking british tea and
then just like oh no it's a bowl or you
know something like that you know
it's a british roast
oh that's good um yeah i would love
olivia coleman in the like steal a cop's
gun challenge
just
um
disney fan has a great one uh tom cruise
in the next jackass movie like tom
cruise takes them into space or
something to do like zero gravity pranks
that's genius disney fan you should you
should just be doing all this training
and then doing none of it
[Laughter]
you know talk to paramount yeah that's
that's brilliant
because that's right
same umbrella yep that could break them
like to see if like what could what will
finally get tom cruise to retire and it
would be like all right he has to film a
whole movie with the jackass guys
someone [ __ ] in your zero g chamber
and it got your hair
he retires
that could do it
looking like uh cameron and diaz and uh
something about mary yes yeah
and um now uh we'll we'll end on a
non-jackass one uh bert pesci asks are
y'all ever going to do an honest trailer
for charlie cox's daredevil are you
holding out just to hurt me
yes it's just you we're just trying to
make your life an endless weight of slog
and suffering no uh we are going to do
it um it is not currently on the
calendar granted the calendar only looks
ahead like a month tops so we will do it
eventually
and um i would love to uh
i don't know it's been like bumped for
one reason or another it's been on and
off the schedule a bunch of times and i
know that there's a lot of very
dedicated people
posting the requests for it uh
repeatedly um it will be done that's all
i can say for now uh we're not avoiding
it out of spite um
uh but stay tuned stay tuned yo if you
want us to do it sooner talk to marvel
like the sooner that they get more
daredevil into stuff the sooner we can
be like okay yeah we can take this other
thing off the schedule at this point i
feel like it is just being held until
like daredevil but he already came back
in the way home yeah no way at home
would have been uh yeah we kind of yeah
yeah whoops uh
but it will uh it'll show up um and uh
you better watch it twice uh for uh for
all the work you've put in um so
next week
next week will not make you happy
i don't know if people have want this or
requested it probably not um but it's
one that if any movie deserves an honest
trailer in recent memory it's it's this
one um
so
when when uh when night falls go look up
in the sky outside your window and shake
your fist at the subject of our next
honest trip
because it's coming oh it's coming um
there's
surprisingly a lot you can do about it
um and we'll cover that all next week
thank you danielle thank you ryan thank
you everyone watching
we'll see y'all then bye-bye
[Music]
you